[Music]
anyway what is this
kim k being a social climber in 2012 the
kardashians were actively banned from
the met gala anna went to a pretty
openly despised the kardashians and no
designer would dress them
but all that changed in 2013 when kanye
took a thor-sized hammer to the doors of
fashion and carried kimmy heavily
pregnant across the threshold demanding
she be acknowledged respected and given
a seat at the table he infamously
cleared out her entire closet revamping
her entire look
taking her from run-of-the-mill reality
star to international fashion it girly
he deployed his fashion photographer
friends to kind of center kim as the new
couture muse called in favors from
designers to get them to dress her
essentially kanye forced the notoriously
snobby fashion world to accept kim and
it worked from 2014 to 2016 kamiye was
the prime fashion power couple
vogue themselves cemented the label
calling them the world's most talked
about couple kim was officially in and
from there kim and kanye worked on
pulling the rest of her family out of
the reality tv trailer park and once
again using kanye's direction styling
and connections it worked people began
seeing the kardashians as a sort of
american neo-royal family the girls went
from a joke to a juggernaut the last
piece of the puzzle was to secure the
bag the big bag
kylie's albeit questionable status as a
billionaire crashed a new ceiling for
the family they figured if she could do
it they could all do it especially kim
kanye was the next
i told him too
[Laughter]
i thought this was joe rogan
can we not [ __ ] smoke
oh you want some
yeah yeah dude i wanted a drag
is that a sound is that a cigarette what
is that it's him it's hemp it's hemp
yeah i don't smoke cigs dude what's the
point of smoking a hemp
cigarette
look how cool i look no you did look
[ __ ] cool yeah you did alexander
skarsgard pulled out a ciggy yeah in the
northman
and just started smoking a cig after
like killing a child
give me one i want who the [ __ ] is kim
does that even do anything no you don't
get a buzz from that at all
so then why do you do it
i definitely want one now
that's real good
oh yeah all right give me one two
coolest book
right
all right it's just hemp dude just you
know
play that dumbass [ __ ] you were just
playing
why did i inhale
you you're supposed to to sick bro blast
it
oh yeah right wow
that tastes exactly like a cigarette
yeah getter put me under these you know
so stupid yeah
these are [ __ ] stupid
why not just smoke real tobacco
are these like just as bad for you
no dude these are good for you
you get that cbd buzz yeah it's got that
it's got that [ __ ] uh yeah it's got
cbd in it probably or some [ __ ] i don't
know sick just asked onto these one of
ones
one of one these chairs oh i think you
mean you're yeah yeah yeah yeah i know
that was weird like on rogan there's
ashtrays
like when i was on road
yeah
this completely just changed the dynamic
of the whole show yeah it really did we
just start smoking we have to talk about
anything important it's more laid back
you can just watch us just do light up
this is actually not a i love that
you're talking to me with the smoke in
your hand it makes it way better that's
what i'm saying cigarettes are cool as
[ __ ] yeah analogs
ash on this foot what is this this
little gamer [ __ ] right here what is
that what do they call this that's
digital [ __ ] yeah we're an analog [ __ ]
bro
don't hash on the stream
zoom in on this what is this nerd thing
right here oh the asteroids
[Laughter]
uh yeah no no problem no problem dude
yeah
dude
it's just like are those ashtrays cool
yeah cool man yeah bring that over here
just ash on his wrist
ow
yeah that's right get the [ __ ] out of
here put it out on his [ __ ] hand
that's what they would do in the
northmen yeah
no dude
so funny uh when i used to deliver
pizzas
um
like
10 years ago
uh i would always just listen to like
talk radio yeah because podcasts weren't
really big at the time
and like it was just entertaining yeah
like ryan seacrest yeah no like weird
talk radio like there's this one channel
that just had like really weird
like old people talk radio
and uh
one of the shows was called like the
cigar dave show
and it was literally just this old dude
talking about smoking cigars and
drinking whiskey
and it [ __ ] ruled like people would
call in and be like hey man like what
type of cigar should i get or whatever
like what should i pair what whiskey
should i pair that with and he'd be like
and you could hear him like puffing a
cigar the whole time [ __ ] whoa
and then just go on so basically that's
what we need to do here yeah this is way
better yeah this really is it's more
relaxed yeah definitely you want to hand
me that cup
nah how's gitter doing by the way
he's good
he's just you know he's a rapper now so
is he is that like that is his main
focus yeah
i mean it's sick yeah
i love that [ __ ] did you want ash in
here yeah
yeah we're high as [ __ ]
we are lit dude dude yeah what is in
these things man bro i envy that so much
what people that have like structured
their creative or i'm being [ __ ] up
while they do it yeah it must feel way
better no it can't probably not weed
maybe yo this layer of just
i look sick right yeah you look cool as
[ __ ] right now
yeah
you don't even need to smoke it you can
just hold it and it's cool
oh what do you what do you guys think
about the kim kardashian thing oh yeah
honestly that i don't give a [ __ ] dude
yeah to be honest i thought it was a
little bit interesting though i just
think it's like
okay like kim kardashian was weird and
like
used somebody all right yeah it's not it
didn't surprise me yeah i mean i uh i
don't know
but it is
it's just yeah i guess everything in
this industry is fake but it surprised
me that you can just become a fashion
icon like i thought you had to have like
a sense it's an art form right yeah yeah
i mean i guess you can kind of become a
[ __ ] music star too
yeah if people are behind the scenes
pulling the strings but
yeah
yeah i don't know it's just like
who gives a [ __ ] yeah yeah i i do i
maybe you could say that you could say
it's shitty because like you know
granted he's lost his noodles but
it's like if he did all that for them
and then they just kind of like yeah
like you're crazy yeah yeah you know he
who [ __ ] cares yeah i just i just
can't say much because like i'm involved
in like a love triangle with her sisters
so oh gotcha yeah
damn the kardashians laid up at night
like stop talking to spock
i'm not
yeah you are that's why i haven't worked
with travis yet yeah yeah yeah or kanye
yeah cause you're [ __ ] their wives
[Laughter]
jesus christ man